okay um
welcome everyone to the ddps seminar um
today um
before we introduce our invited speakers
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions if
you have questions you are welcome to
mute and ask
otherwise please use chatroom to post
your questions so that we can address
them in granny session at the end second
today's ddps seminar is open to external
audiences therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now uh let me introduce
our speaker today it is an honor to host
professor wayne and e
who is a professor in the school of
mathematical science in at packing
university and the professor in the
department of mathematics and
program
in applied and computational mathematics
at
princeton university his main research
interest is numerical algorithms machine
learning and multiscale modelling with
applications to chemistry material
sciences and fluid mechanics
in recent years he has also developed an
interest in control theory and related
fields raynan
was awarded the iciam
coolest prize in 2003 and and many other
numerous uh the owers
and
today wayne and will give a talk about
machine learning and multi-scale
modeling please expect a wonderful talk
and enjoy it and now without further due
let me pass the button to professor
weiner by asking our usual question that
is what is your favorite things to do
other than research
i cannot think of any
um
actually maybe staying with the family
or something like that staying with the
family oh so you're
you're like almost 100 100 focusing on
your research i guess
well other than the research i don't
know what else
to do okay stay with the family
yeah yeah all right sounds good stage is
yours is that an unexpected question
okay 15 years yeah yeah thank you very
much yansu for the
invitation and from the direction
so i'll focus on something which really
i worked on very very many years namely
multi-scale modeling
and honestly
you know i wrote this book
i those book 2011
principles of multi-scale modeling
perhaps one of the hardest book to read
um because i at the time ten years ago
because i felt
that you know this paradigm of
multi-scale modeling even though it's
extremely attractive
i felt at the time that
really wasn't going anywhere you know
really we were really
hitting the walls
and i i thought i just wrapped up what i
understood about the subject and turn
down something else and there's
something else i turn onto
i decided to turn on to was
was machine learning
and you know to my surprise
machine learning seemed to be the
missing tool
that we didn't have
uh in multi-scale modeling and and and
it it certainly changed my perspective
on multi-scale modeling so that's what
i'm focused on machine learning-based
multi-scale modeling and the key
question
is how we can construct interpretable
and truly reliable physical models
using concurrent
machine learning
so let me explain this
we really want new physical models it's
not just an algorithm but we really want
new physical models just like fluid
mechanics equations like new navy stokes
type of equations
and in order to have that
you know for that purpose we really want
to want the model to be interpretable
that's
one requirement for being a physical
model and truly reliable so
that's one thing i need to stress
um
nowadays it's fairly easy to you know
run some simulation get some data and
using
high torch or tensorflow to come up with
a machine learning model in a new
network model that fit the data very
well so that's fairly easy to do
that doesn't mean we have a
truly reliable physical model
and there's a very big difference
in the two so that's one thing i want to
address uh stress the second i want to
stress is concurrent machine learning as
i was
explaining in more detail below
usual machine learning that people are
doing in ai
in our language in the language of
multi-scale modeling would be called
sequential because somebody produced the
data beforehand
and then somebody else does the machine
learning to fit the data
so that's a sequential mode
and the kind of machine learning we we
we were faced
are concurrent
if you know about
if you heard about these terminologies
in multi-scan modeling there was
sequential multiscale modeling and
concurrent multiscale modeling so in the
multistream of the machine learning
where we're doing is also concurrent in
the sense that you generate the data on
the fly
as you train the machine learning model
so i'm going to let explain these things
more in detail
but let me mention my collaborators
roberto carr and princeton gentleman
with black iron
and juan lay in
michigan state university and hang on
and lingbang are both in beijing
okay let me start with this multi-scale
modeling paradigm we have a hierarchy of
physical models down from
from a shooting
quantum mechanics to density functional
theory classical molecular dynamics
coarse grain molecular dynamics that's
often used in
say um
chemical engineering or biomolecular
modeling and both my equations
um
continue mechanics like like in fluids
or or solids elasticity and turbulence
models so this is a perhaps the
a comprehensive
list of
all the most basic physical models that
we use in
different subjects of science and
engineering
now the difficulties with these models
is that other than the schrodinger
equation
all these other models requires some
some modeling component by which i mean
for example
um the uh well let's come here for
example the considerable equations in
conditional mechanics
and the
the uh
the potential energy function
in molecular dynamics or the density or
the exchange correlation function
now in density functional theory these
are part of the
the the model
that we need to come up with
so
in the old days how do we come up with
the models so for example
this has been this has been a huge
problem for example
in uh
in
non-newtonian fluids we need to come up
with these uh
these considerable equations and there
is lots of
proposals like generalized newtonian
model maxwell models
rotational code informational models and
they're all
at a hawk in a way
so
the problem with this these models is
that they're not very reliable
and then the same story can be
same story
is also happening in other situations
for example in turbulence it's well
known
that we need to come up with these ad
hoc heuristic terminus models like
capsule models in
in brands
and in density functional theory there's
different proposals about how to
model exchange correlation functionals
and et cetera et cetera so
in the absence in absence of systematic
methods
we have to resort to ad-hoc approaches
now
20 years ago
something was
very popular
very hot actually was with multi-scale
algorithms
so the idea of multi-scale algorithms is
to say okay
we don't have any reliable macro scale
model
but suppose we have a reliable micro
scale model
so can we come up with
can we come up with
numerical algorithms
that'll model the macroscopic phenomena
but only use
microscopic models
that was sort of the
the the dream of multiscale modeling so
in order to bypass the need to come up
with these ad hoc models
now one of the
uh i would say one of the representative
algorithms was called heterogeneous
multi-scale method proposed by ankus and
myself
and the idea is this is exactly what i
just described we have this this guy
this is the micro scale model we assume
we have and it's reliable
and this guy the macroscopic model we
don't have
now but we're interested in modeling at
this level now the the heterogeneous
multiscale method is a methodology that
allows us to do that in principle
now
we don't need to worry about the details
but that is just one of the ideas
proposed at the time in order to what uh
to do what i just said
now the difficulty was such an idea
um the why it wasn't so successful as as
why it wasn't as successful as as we
expected after many years of
of trying
the difficulty comes off comes
uh
as follows
there are several difficulties one is
that the microscopic model itself
is not really very reliable either so
this guy oftentimes is not very reliable
for example if you want to do crack
propagation
and you use molecular dynamics to model
the
as the microscopic model the
molecular dynamic itself
is often not very reliable because
you know
especially for correct propagation when
the breaking of chemical balance is
involved so
that's one problem
the second problem is that
the scale that we need to do the
microscopic simulation microscale
simulation is often too hot to be too
large it's still out of rich
and then thirdly
perhaps most importantly is that there's
no clear scale separation
so the microscope
the macro scale and the micro scale
there's no
clear scale separation
now
so that these are the difficulties
essential difficulties that we had
we we had earlier but at the technical
level there is another difficulty
which is
that in order to perform multi-scale
algorithms
we need a effective tool
to extract information out of these
microscopic simulation and put that into
the
macro scale simulation so we need some
tool to extract data
this data estimation step
and at that time
we didn't have
such an effective tool
and the difficulty with that
is
is that we have too many degrees of
freedom
for example when you do turbulence
modeling there's just too many degrees
of freedom many
many things matter at the macro scale
and as diminished as dimensionality
grows
complexity grows up exponentially so
this is the cursive dimensionality so
that was the essential
difficulty other than these three
difficulties
that are listed here
the the the the other difficulty
is this lack of tools to it
to to do the data estimation data
processing
and this is exactly where machine
learning can help
machine learning provides a way to solve
this curse of dimensionality problem so
why do i say that let me give you an
example this is the one of the most
well-known example that deep learning
can do
which is classification of images so
this is the
famous data set called c510
it's called 10 because all these images
comes into ten categories so airplanes
deer cats dogs etc
so the the the
the um
um
the uh
given this data set
given this data set and this data set
the images are labeled into one of these
10 categories now the
objective
is to predict
if new images of the same type comes in
we need to automatically predict which
category the image the new image is
supposed to be in
so this is
a classification image problem
and we can think of this as being
a
a function approximation problem
and the function the target function
is a function that maps each image to
its category
so
let's say f star is a target function so
that function is defined in the space of
images and the value takes
contained values according to the
category
so now this function
this function approximation problem
is very different from the kind of
function approximation problem that we
encountered in numerical analysis
for a very long time
in the sense that
the
the domain we are working with
lives in very high dimension
so we count the dimensionality namely
the number of degrees of freedom
you'll see that each pixel is a degree
of freedom so we have 32 by 32 pixels
in addition
these images are colored images
there's there's a three dimensionality
there's dimensionality of three
in the space of color
so all together
these
the function f star is defined
on a space of 3072 dimensions so we're
trying to approximate a function
in a three dimension 3072 dimensional
space
so this is a huge
uh dimensionality that we never have
would have thought about to do
in the old days
but
deep learning seemed to be performing
such tasks very well
so why this is the case
let me briefly discuss why
deep learning can
you know handle a function approximation
in such high dimension
so first let me say why classical
approximation theory doesn't work in
high dimension
well classical approximation theory
um
uses polynomials of piecewise
polynomials web let's splines
um
and and
and
things like that two approximate
functions
now the class the kind of uh
error estimates we have
in classical approximation theory often
looks like this so the left hand side is
the error the right hand side we have
a product of two quantities uh one
quantity the first term
is m to the minus alpha over d so here m
is the total number of degrees of
freedom in the approximation scheme like
total number of
nodes you will find element mesh
d is the dimensionality
alpha is something associated with the
approximation algorithm and this
quantity is like a quantity associated
with a target function like
some norm of the target function
now with such so this kind of error
estimates tells us
if we want to reduce the error by a
factor of 10
we need to increase
m by a factor of 10 to the d over alpha
let's take alpha to be one
so that means we need to increase m
the total number of degrees of freedom
in that approximation algorithm by 10 to
the d if g is 3072 this is truly a huge
number
so this is the problem with the
classical approximation theory
and it's generic
it's generic
now
this doesn't mean
that we cannot do anything high
dimension there's one situation in which
uh in a high dimensional situation in
which we have developed a very
successful numerical algorithms and this
is integration so if we want to perform
this integration problem
in uh in high dimension we approximate
that
integral by a sum
here mu is the probability distribution
say the uniform distribution
let's say the bigger measure
so we approximate by this integral by a
sum if we do something like trapezoidal
rule
or simpson's rule
it's easier to see that we also have
this curve's cursive dimensionality
problem the error goes like m to the
minus alpha over d alpha is something
that depends on the uh
whether it's trapezoidal rule or
simpson's rule
but if we do
monte carlo
then the error this is exact
that the error is variance over n so
error squared
is variance over n
so you can see
so sorry this n is um
in the m this would be
n actually n is the number of nodes this
would be n also so there's no one over d
in the exponent
this means the the convergence rate is
independent of dimensionality of course
the variance could be high in high
dimension so that's why we need some
various reductions but in any case we do
have an algorithm
whose convergence rate does not
deteriorate as dimensionality grows up
as a matter of fact in statistical
physics
people perform
um
integration of functions in millions of
dimensions and that's
that that's gone fairly routinely now so
routine that we forget how remarkable
this fact is
what do we need what we need to do
is to
do the same thing but not just for
computing integral but rather for
approximating functions and that's what
machine learning does
so we can divide machine learning models
abstractly into two categories two kind
categories the first category are models
that do suffer from cursive
dimensionality so for example piecewise
polynomial approximation wavelets so
these kinds or um
or fixed basis
um
fixed basis algorithms in machine
learning like
so these are these are these are models
that do suffer from the crystal
dimensionality there are other class of
algorithms
like neural network models
whose error
whose error behaves like this you have
some constants over m m is the number of
degrees of freedom and then you have
some other constant over square root of
n n is the number of data points
so we can show i'm not going to go into
the details we can show that there are
machine learning algorithms
particularly neural network models for
which the generalization error does look
like this so this is very much like the
monte carlo
kind of bounce but now for function
approximation
as i you know said
several uh we can show several
neural network models do fall into this
category
so these are the kind of machines these
are the kind of models
that can help us to overcome the curse
of dimensionality problem
now our objective
is to use these kinds of machine
learning models to help us to do
multi-scale modeling as i have mentioned
before we want to
construct interpretable and true
reliable physical models and we want to
deal with situations for which there is
no clear separation of scales
and
and i i want to stress that this isn't
a
non-trivial problem so let me say
something about current concurrent
machine learning
so sequential machine so this
terminology
is borrowed
from multi-scale modeling where we talk
about sequential multi-scale modeling
and concurrent multi-scale modeling so
sequential multi-scale modeling would be
pre-computing you pre-compute something
and you plug it into a macro scale model
so concurrent mod multi-scale modeling
would be doing these things on the
flight but doesn't buy it doesn't buy uh
doesn't do by pre-computing but rather
do it on a fly now here's the same thing
if you
in machine learning if you first collect
a label of data and then perform
learning and this is a concur and this
is sequential so most machine learning
problems in ai are sequential somebody
collects the data somebody else does the
learning
now we will be dealing with concurrent
learning in the sense that we need to
generate data on the fly
as machine learning proceeds i'll show
that
in the concluding examples in a minute
and in this case we need to think about
how to generate optimal data set
and the reason for doing that
as i uh i'll explain in a minute so let
me
let me use molecular dynamics as a
concrete example so molecular dynamics
we're solving newton's equation
for
a system of big n atoms
and so this is newton's equation now the
the difficulty is that we need
a model for the potential image function
so classically there were two ideas
the first idea let me say the first idea
is to use empirical potential
for example something like the little
jones potential
so this would work for
inert gas systems of inert gas but
we're not interested in their gas very
much we're interested in metals
semiconductors and alloys and stuff like
that and in in in those cases
it's much harder
to come up with accurate and reliable
you know reliability is the key it's
very difficult to come up with reliable
empirical potentials even though there
are many ones that are used
in popular use
but still unite reliability is a problem
so this is the one approach the other
approach
is to compute these forces on the fly
using quantum mechanics such as density
functional theory
so the first example is the carbonyl
molecular dynamics
so then we will be solving you know
together with
systems of equation of the nuclei will
also be solving a system of equations
for the electrons
and this is very expensive because each
time you're you're doing a density
function or theory calculation
so this is accurate but you know
reliable but expensive so this is the
dilemma we have always been for facing
classically namely the
the
choice between reliability and
efficiency
now we have a new paradigm with machine
learning we have a new paradigm
quantum mechanics models like basically
functional theory is only a data
generator it only helps us to generate
data and then we use machine learning
to parametrize
the data and get something some some
some formula like like these but these
are now machine learning formulas
and then we do molecular dynamics so
this will be a new paradigm
now in order to do this
we need to address two questions
how do we make sure that the data how to
where do we get the data how to make
sure the data is good enough and then
in for the machine learning model it's
not just the machine learning model
usual machine ai machine learning model
we need to respect physical constraints
like symmetries so how do we do that
so let me first talk about
constructing the model you know what
kind of neural network model we need to
uh to construct in situations like this
the first
requirement is that the new network
model has to be extensive
namely if you do a machine learning
model for a thousand atoms and in
practice you are dealing with a million
atoms you need to be able to
extend very simply in a very simple way
the model you have a thousand atoms to a
model for milling atoms so this is done
by making sure that the neural network
model is extensive
now here's one idea this idea is
proposed by bella and paranello i didn't
have i should have the uh
sorry i should have the reference here
but i didn't have
oh maybe i've missed all the references
sorry
so bella paranello 2007 2007 in a paper
in uh
physical review letters propose this
extensive model so each one of these
guys
so you have
this is the compulsive neural network
model each atom each nuclei corresponds
to one sub network so say you have the
first atom the first atom has a little
neighborhood and these are all the atoms
in the positions of the atoms that
neighborhood and then you construct some
you know sub network that corresponds to
this first atom and the total energy is
the sum of all the energy contributions
from every atom now you need you don't
need to decide which atom contributes
how much energy this is all done
automatically
now each sub-network
looks like a usual neural network you
have these coordinates of the of the
atoms in the neighborhood and then you
construct
uh a neural network model so this is a
sort of
uh
this is a an extensive neural network
and the second issue is to impose
symmetry
so we have
translational rotational symmetry and we
also have permutational symmetry namely
if you relabel the atoms of same species
you know the total energy should not be
the shouldn't should be the same so
that's permutation of symmetry now
if you don't impose permutation these
symmetries
then
the accuracy would substantially
deteriorate so this is the
illustration this is the accuracy for
the force this is the accuracy for the
energy the the red line shows the result
after imposing symmetry and the blue
line shows the result if you don't
impose symmetry you'll see that the
error differs
there's a one or two magnitude of
difference in terms of the accuracy
so imposing symmetry is important
the simplest way to impose such a
symmetry is to just to fix the local
coordinate frame you fix you know for
each atom you define a local coordinate
frame by fix the origin on that atom and
then you select some you know x-axis
y-axis z-axis and if you
if you
fix that local
frame of reference you have taken care
of translational rotational symmetry
and then
in the little neighborhood you know
these guys
in these guys you just fix some ordering
of these atoms and by that you also fix
the permutation of symmetry
if you do that
it works that's what generates
these uh figures it seems you know seem
to be working
you know the the the um training the
testing and training accuracy are
very good but
if you do molecular dynamics and you'll
see that the total energy slowly drifts
this is the this is the blue line and
that's not good
that's not
that's not good because that that poor
man's version of taking care of the
symmetry
require create small discontinuities for
example
when the atoms go in and out go out and
in
or
in the neighborhood or when the the
ordering changes a little bit you create
a small discontinuity that's more
discontinuity doesn't show up when you
just
uh
test on the in the test accuracy
but it shows up when you do molecular
dynamics for a long time so therefore we
have we need to have a better way to pre
to um impose symmetries and that's
shown by this little lemma here
the rotational symmetry can be fixed if
every quantity
is you know if the the the the the
quantities we're
having at the end depends only on the
inner product
you know things like this
and permutation of symmetry
is uh taken care of if
if
the forces look like this so here's a
little lemma that um
that might be useful
a function a permutation or symmetric
function
can be written can always be written in
such a form you know we can always
choose some row or some g so that
um
so that the the function
can be decomposed in this form
so therefore if our if the um neural
network we come up with in the end only
requires quantity only requires
dependence on such quantities or in this
form then
the uh rotational translation rotational
permutation of symmetries are
romantically taken care of
and translational symmetry is easily
taken care of because of um if we just
define the local coordinates
okay so this is how this is a messy
slice but that's how that shows the how
we impose this idea
so the neural network we have
uh
a composition of two parts
the first part
is sort of embedding
network
by embedding the local coordinates into
symmetric
into
you know
dependence of functions like this
and the second part is a fitting network
that really fits the energy
okay
so this the the structure of the
embedding is shown in here so these g's
are functions of this type of the type
that we just
okay this is the better formula here
so
these features
are
the result of the embedding the first
part
now the first after the first part all
the quantity is four
and the second part depends only on
quantities of these forms features of
this form so that ensures automatically
that the symmetries are
respected
and then these these these little g's
are also modeled by new network models
okay that's the first part how do we
construct a neural network model that
both extensive and
and respect the invariance the
symmetries the second part is how do we
generate the data
now each data
needs to be labeled
meaning computing the energy and forces
on the on on the atoms
by
performing a
quantum mechanics calculation like a dft
calculation so this
that's the labeling process for each
now
so you know
that's a very expensive calculation
and we
so in order to um
to generate
to generate the data we need to make
sure two things
one is that we want the data set to be
representative enough
so that all the uh situation in practice
that we need we might encounter are
represented in some way in our data set
and secondly we want to make sure that
data set is as small as possible because
each data point is expensive calculation
so in order to to meet that purpose we
developed
something called called
an exploration labeling and training
procedure
so exploration
is that is is a step
that we just explore the configuration
space of the uh of the system so if you
want to deal with a system of
water molecules you
explored the configuration space of the
water molecules
and that's done by
by uh well
there are many ways to do that you can
do some you can do some monte carlo
steps or molecular diameter steps but
the key thing here is that you want to
explore the places where
where where it's of radical interest and
where you don't have enough data
so that's the key thing so we need to
develop some algorithms that
automatically goes through places where
where where we don't have enough data
so this is some biased molecular
dynamics that we developed
and then
for each configuration that we that you
we that we explore
we need to decide whether that
configuration needs to be labeled
and that that's done that
okay
let me
let me show this figure so the sampling
step is an exploration you explore the
different configurations that you might
that might be encountering practice
and once you have a configuration you
need to decide whether that
configuration needs to be labeled
now a configuration needs to be labeled
if we don't have enough data around that
configuration
so that's the general principle so how
would it how do we decide whether we
have enough data
whether our machine learning model is
accurate enough at that particular
data point well one way to do that
is that we train an ensemble of models
we don't train just one model
we train and ensemble models
in places where we have enough data and
and the machine learning model is
accurate then this ensemble models would
predict
pre give very much the
same
very similar predictions
which means the variance
from a different
prediction would be small
now in places where we don't have enough
data
and the machine learning model is not
accurate enough
this variance will be large so this
indicator
serves this variant serves as a good
um
whether we need to label the data point
and once we need we decide that the data
point needs to be labeled we do
eft calculation
uh to label the data and then we do the
training so this procedure is a
is a um
sort of self-learning procedure
concurrent learning procedure that can
be repeated
indefinitely
until we have satisfactory model so this
is the exploration
labeling and training procedure and to
show you that this really makes a big
difference let's look at this
example here here we want to train
a
reliable
aluminum magnesium
model for aluminum magnesium alloy
you'll see that the
the exploration
procedure gives us
half the billing
configurations
out of which the procedure only
a
procedure that i just described the
exploration labeling and training
procedure only requires us to label less
than 20 000 configurations
so this is a huge saving compared with
labeling half a million configurations
and this is already good enough this
already gives us
you know
very good accuracy
and
for the
for the machine learning model and this
has been tried on different systems
ranging from small molecules big
molecules
high entropy alloys
oxidized surface materials and you know
simple metal alloys and stuff like that
and you can see
that always gives
this uh
an accuracy that's comparable to the
accuracy of the underlying quantum
mechanics model here the quantum
mechanics modus the dft model
and if you compare
like the radio distribution function
angular distribution function some other
parameters you don't see any difference
between
the potential molecular dynamics by the
way because steep potential molecular
dynamics
you you know keep md
and compare with um past integral you
know
or or i've initially md you don't see
any difference
and we'll try this one of the success
story with this is that we tried on
the the um
water
water is a quite complicated system
um
in terms of its phase diagram
and then we were able to qualitably
reproduce the phase diagram of water
and combined with the summit
we'll put this in the summit
and we were able to um
to extend
our initial molecular dynamics from
being able to handle a thousand atoms to
being able to handle
uh
100 million atoms act this is actually
two years ago now we can handle
10 billion atoms
with um
with the of initial accuracy so this is
the
2020 golden bell price
now
i think the importance of this work here
no it's not
is that it really shows you
by combining machine learning with um
with scientific computing and high
performance computing you know how much
gain how big a room that we have here
and we have actually developed the open
source platform the deep empty kit
and where
people can
use and contribute this deep modeling
open source platform our hope is that
you know people in the community can
contribute this can work on this
together and construct some platform
where everybody can use we don't have to
like before we do everything from the
beginning to the end by by
by you know each team you know we can
work together could construct such a
platform and do
and this has been quite successful
there's a very active discussion group
and many you know has been able to help
solve many problems from battery
materials high entropy alloys organic
chemistry bio molecular modeling and you
know lots of
as i said phase diagram water
anyway many many problems have been
solved with this
so this is my first example let me turn
briefly to a second example so
this is the added a
we're interested in a bigger scale
into you know in the previous example
molecular modeling we're interested in
we're interested in atomistic scale so
now we are interested in a bigger scale
we want to model
the
fluid mechanics
of polymer
fluids
and again this is a classical difficult
problem
continuum
hydrodynamic models of
non-returning fluids looks like this we
talk about um
some solvent solutes
uh polymers in the solvent
polymer solution so here the stress
so this is the incompressibility this is
the momentum equation the stress comes
from two parts comes from there's a new
toning part for the solvent and then
there is this polymer part and the
polymer part that's difficult
now classically there's been different
uh models like hooking
pdp models hooky models and then they're
more
more uh
complicated models like these um
dynamical models where c is some sort of
a confirmation tensor
when
okay so this
had this is sort of a incompressible
nanotuning food models
now the problem with these empirical
models
is that
it it's very difficult to relate these
empirical closure models
to molecular fidelity
if you have a different molecular
structure
you know how how is it going to
different how how would
these a
closure and how closure models be
different
and then
other than that
this guy
this derivative here
what is called objective tensor
derivative of objective uh objective
means that it has to be
um framing different
now this
derivative here
because c is a tensor
can take different form
you know the the requirement of object
of objectivity does not
um give our give rise to a single choice
for example in the literature we have
seen up convective derivative we have
seen this covariant derivative we're
going to see this co-rotational
derivative
now which choice should be selected we
don't know
okay and then you know it's very
difficult to generalize to different
experimental situations
so now we have
we're going to do this using machine
learning so our idea id our idea here is
that we have some micro scale model
which would be molecular dynamics of
some polymer
uh
polymer fluids and from which we're
going to generate some confirmation
tensor and then
these conformation tensor we're going to
develop
dynamic equations accurate dynamic
equations for this conformation tensor
now
the first
issue is how do we generate these
confirmation tensor
so we want to generate this confirmation
tensor so that it best
represents the configurations
of the mic the microscopic configuration
so the
so-called micro macro correspondence
okay
okay now
of course the underlying molecular
structure could be different
simple ideas could be like dumbbell
models could be multi-beat models and
also we want these symmetries rotational
symmetry and stuff like that to be
uh to be enforced
the second idea so once we generate
these these uh
confirmation tensor once we decided what
the conformation tensors are we need to
come up with these
with with them with these equations
accurate approximations of these
equations
and here we're going to start with the
microscopic focal planck equation for
these molecules
for the um
distributions of these um
of the config configurations
and starting from that
we can derive
at least formally an equation
for the uh for the dynamics of these
tensors
okay so of course we don't know how
these brackets
we don't know how to express this
brackets that's the closure problem that
we've always encountered
but now we can use machine learning
to fit a function
that up that closely approximate
approximately this bracket
so in this way we automatically generate
a
a objective tensor derivative and we
automatically
give accurate approximations of these
dynamic equations and these kind of
equations are interpretable in a way
also
okay so this is the um
dp n squared model it's called deep
learning based non-newtonian dynamics
fluid dynamics so n squared stands from
non-newtoni and it takes this form
okay so the details don't matter the
details involve some detailed um your
network models in the spirit of what i
just discussed before but in the end the
equation looks like this so it's very
much like the classical equations except
that you know these tensors and these
these um terms
are based on machine learning
so let me show you some example so the
first example is
um
simple um personal flow
of dumbbell fluids these are dumbbell
flutes and you can see that
that you know this is the velocity this
is the stress you can see these red
lines
and a result of the md and the dashed
lines are result of the defense depends
squared model
and they're com they're very close but
if you do
if you do hooking or fining p model
this is the finite p this is the hooking
they're very far apart and similarly for
the stress
and
and this is the
generalized derivative
of objective tensor derivative and you
can see that it's also
modeled very accurately by the deep end
square model
but if you do the um the other guys
okay now
here we talk about how molecular shape
different molecules the star-shaped b
this is the beta springs and this is a
more complicated shape
you know how the microstructure
affects the the macros macro scale flow
so we have
this is still in
the in the polyflow framework but we at
some time will reverse the the direction
of the polarized flow and then you can
see that the brain square model captures
the behavior very accurately and you can
see this almost like hysteresis book
this is not a real historical look but
you can see these loops are captured
very accurately by the by the dependent
square model
and this is the example of a 2d taylor
vortex model and you can see that this
is a chain molecule this is a star
molecule the the um
the molecular shape really
affects the macroscopic scale flow the
physical elastic response
in a dramatic way and it's captured very
well by this mod
okay let me conclude
i would say the integration of machine
learning with the physics-based modeling
opens up a whole new chapter in the way
we do scientific and engineering
modeling
and concurrent learning so what we we
encounter in these problems
are concurrent machine learning problems
and they
and that
that's required
in order to generate an optimal data set
because labeling is very expensive so
generating optimal data set is very
important for these procedures to be
effective
and so concurrent learning learning this
idea of of
adaptively generating data sets on the
fly
is important
and it's important to take physics into
account
so the neural network model and the
dynamic equations has to respect the
underlying physics
that's done by you know imposing the
right symmetry or you know deriving the
macroscopic model from the microscope
my underlying microscope my micro scale
model and then do the closure
so and i also want to emphasize that
what do we get is our new physical
models not just algorithms so it's not
we're not just talking about the
algorithm these guys here
are a new potentially a new set of
equations just like euler's equation i
remember when i was graduate student we
were doing euler's equation for gas
dynamics with the
so-called real gas and the equation of
state for real gas was an issue how do
we get the equation of state well
at the time we were
getting equation of state for real gas
from a table
generated and i think
i don't know i think it's um los anos
um from experimental data so they
measured did some experimental
measurements and then fit the data by a
spline and stored that as a subroutine
and we were just calling that subroutine
for
as as the source of the equation of
state and here it's very much the same
thing you know it's a little more
complicated
than the equation of state here we have
a new set of considerable equations
and it's also more complicated in the
sense that splines will be replaced by
machine learning so these formulas are
machine learning formulas but other than
that philosophically they're very close
so i would say these are really a new
set of physical models they're
interpretable and they're supposed to be
reliable and we just we should use them
just like euler's equations gas dynamics
and this
is
um
what i want to say and thank you very
much for that
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk uh uh professor wayne and
um
i enjoyed it a lot um thank you
uh there's a um
many many questions posted by
professor lange
most of them you can ignore um
but but i do i do have one in one so so
i i they're worth going back and reading
because i did note that uh some of the
the terms you introduced there are more
well established very well established
terms in the machine learning literature
and i would encourage you to use them
things like online and offline learning
and active learning you are doing the
same thing
it's a good idea uh it's a great idea
but there's no reason to introduce new
terms when we've been told in these
things for 30 plus years um
the but the the serious question is uh
and i've been listening for the over the
past couple years to people from the
computational science community in the
physics community who are using starting
to use machine learning and there's two
kinds of talks there's one where they're
using machine learning to try and speed
up the simulation of a model that they
already believe is correct
and the other is where they're trying to
discover new laws
if i understood correctly you didn't say
this as explicitly as you might have the
first two thirds of your talk was about
the first
problem and the last part was about the
second problem is that correct or
incorrect
um okay first of all about terminology
so i should have explained the
difference between active learning
and uh
online learning with concurrent learning
so um
i think there is a big difference
for example active learning you have
unlabeled data
already given to you and you decide
which one is the label
and here
uh here in our case that's sorry that's
not true that it you maybe the maybe
most of the examples you've come across
in literature are like that but there
are many examples of active learning
where you actually select new instances
that aren't even in a data set yet they
don't they're not unlabeled instances
they just don't exist and you have to
produce them that counts and there have
examples of that
okay so
okay we might have to argue about this
forever so let me start about arguing
about this okay so um i i would insist
there's a difference i've talked with
people you know about okay let's talk
about this now with respect to the
second question
the the
in in the sense you're right i mean the
first example all we need to do is to
fit a function the the potential image
function
it's still hard it's just i just want to
be clear about what the task is
well yeah i mean it's a hard task but
it's but we just need to fit the
function we need to get a function so
that's
that's very much um
you know
the first category the second kind of
the second part
it is true we yeah the um
the um it's a little bit more than
fitting the function it's um
getting the form of the equations and
stuff like that so yes yes i understand
i understand that we used to call it
equation discovery some other people
call it symbolic regression um some
people call it law discovery uh yeah
that's an old idea that goes back to
even before the the other task
so but that but i have not seen it
applied in this context and i and i
certainly am excited about your results
so thank you i mean i just i'm a i'm a
big fan of stating explicitly
what computational problem you're
working on and these are two different
computational problems with different
inputs and different out different
outputs
and even if you're using the same
underlying technology the problems are
somewhat different and that's all i was
asking for clarification about
okay
i'll keep that into
keep that in mind and try to do a better
job next time
thank you it depends on who you're
speaking to i mean you know people in
from a computer science background love
to know
what the computational abstract action
is and uh and
and so that's that's where i'm coming
from okay thank you thank you so much um
is there any other question from the
audience i don't i don't see anything i
asked a question yeah sure yeah thank
you for the nice part uh okay i'll go
back to the slide where you show a few
equations to trade the
permutation symmetry
here uh uh can i cancel the equations uh
for the permutation symmetry yes
this one
yeah
so i'm i'm trying to understand these
equations so so does it mean that uh
for any uh interaction potential
of
many body system you can always
decompose it into
uh like
terrorized interaction
no no that's not true okay
so
it's okay
uh
okay
it might be
misleading so let's forget about one
index you can see that you know there is
always an i carried around so that's a
little misleading so forget about the
eye so it's just j ah
so here i is around because it's talking
about the the this needs to be done for
all the atoms
and this is the eyes atom we're talking
about so
so i that doesn't mean it's pairwise in
action
not at all
okay thank you
all right um thank you how
is there any other question
from audience
you can
unmute yourself and
ask questions
um i don't think there's there's any
other question professor lange maybe you
can yeah please anyone else can go first
i i'm happy to have you go first
so so in the in the last uh results that
you showed us i would like to understand
better how you define and constrain the
space of equations that you're searching
it's clear there is such there is a
space i just don't know what it is
and in particular
are you searching it so so is this so
are do all but do you specify the
functional form and and and fit the
parameters or do you actually search a
space of different functional forms and
if so what what is that space
okay
the starting point is the
plunge equation for the underlying
scale model
and from that focal plug equation we can
formally derive a equation for the
tensor c we're interested in so that's
this equation
okay so then in this equation we have
three brackets
we need to
we need to um
do a closure problem so we need to
um
fund
find express these brackets in terms of
quantities that we already have like c
like these these c's
so that's a
that's the machine learning part so we
um
we assume that this is a function this
is these guys a function of the
quantities we have already have
and we find that particular function by
performing machine learning
well i since i don't know what you mean
by a closure i'm probably not we're
probably not going to communicate today
but
if anyone else
do you know by moment moment closure
not a clue no
okay so that's okay um
if if you were going to
if so for example for this particular
problem
how if if you were
going to enumerate all possible
equation forms how many would there be
so is that because they differ in
parameters or because they differ in
their structure
there could be different structure
then there's probably not an infinite
set
but at least if you put some so is there
a bound on complexity
so now i see you come from a computer
science background well actually
psychology but yes psychology okay
that's close enough for us
okay now in in our in our world things
are continuous not discrete so by being
infinite doesn't mean much you know
but in this case
it's the kind of
structures you could have is really just
enormous you shouldn't you shouldn't be
searching in the space of you know
equations
so what i'm saying here is that you
should start with the underlying
microscopic model try to perform
a symbolic formal calculation like this
one here and then then you have well
since you don't know about closure i
don't know what this it's probably
difficult to explain but you know the
the moment closure is a very typical
example that we offer in current
physical modeling
and here we're just using machine
learning to help us to do the closure
problem okay just just for the record
there's been plenty of work on equation
discovery scientific model discovery
that does search the space of symbolic
structures and also does parameter
estimation so so now you're if you're
not doing that that's fine and i'd like
to understand it better but there are
plenty of positive results where people
have done that um so again these are
different paradigms that's okay that's
why we have a lot to learn from each
other so thank you for your
talk thank you thank you
is there any other um
one more question on this slide so this
uh micro macro correspondence
um so
what kind of uh averaging is performed
here and um
do you find any dependence on the
resolution of this um
you know how you block average this
microscopic
properties to into your microscopic
properties
okay so that's a very very good question
the um
so the average perform the the average
that's performed here in in principle
that average review performed with
respect to the
situation
in um
that you encounter in practice for
example if you're doing flow then
you know this will be the configurations
the probability distribution for the
microstructure in the flow
so here what's done is
yeah
and here what's done is that we are
doing
equilibrium averaging
so generate some equilibrium states
and then perform this
kind of a quantity
all right
you would say gibbs distribution
or canonical ensemble
all right thank you so much professor
i have a related question yeah go ahead
go ahead oh uh hi everyone this is ahmed
alright
very nice talk
so do you my question is related to
again the question that she asked do you
run into time scale problem or skill
problem when you do this averaging
seriously
uh do you run into multi-scale issues
um
when you do this averaging
like is the system stuck
stuck like the same problem as we have
in molecular dynamics is the system
stops somewhere
it's unable to explore the space that
you wanted to explore when you're doing
this algorithm
um
not not here really because
because um there is no um
well system size is not that hard and
there is no um
barrier crossing events associated with
here so this is a linear
almost like you know it's not linearly
responsive regime it's not your response
but you know it's in that category
it
is what i'm saying there's no
in this
in there's no barrier crossing you know
that's also because of we are doing
simple rather simple molecules at the
moment
if you do like very long-chain big
molecules
you would still have the
the the issue that you just said just
you know get stuck
at the moment no
okay thank you
all right is there any other questions
well um
if there's no more question let's let's
thank our speaker professor e
it was a wonderful cook
and
and uh um you know i was delighted to
see the the goal the your
golden golden bell prize uh the examples
uh in one of the slides um
and
in
in lawrence live on national that there
are many molecular dynamics and they
tried to
get that award as well
so it was nice it's nice to see that all
right
thank you so much
with that i think we can wrap up
i wish that with this talk
i hope there will be a lot more
collaborations between
um you know lawrence livermore and um
maybe pecking university because you're
transferring from the princeton to
pacquiao right now so
yeah let's
let's
let's hope that's going to happen
all right thank you again
thank you thank you for the invitation
thank you thank you so much